[Music]
[Applause]
Hello. Hello.
[Music]
Okay, my slides are up. You can see
them, right?
It's me. Okay. Well, this is a very
special moment for me because I just
realized yesterday walking in, this is
the exact same spot, the same stage
actually, that I stepped on almost
exactly day for day 10 years ago to kick
off Docker Con 2015.
Thought it was pretty funny. I don't
know if anyone was there for that. Maybe
this audience is too young. Maybe. I
don't know.
Okay. Well, uh, I'm here to talk about
chaos, specifically the kind of chaos
that emerges when you try to use, uh,
coding agents. Um, and
I want to talk about chaos from the
perspective of our community at Dagger,
which is platform engineers.
Um, I don't know if there's any platform
engineers in the room.
Okay, just y me, ma'am.
Okay. Well, it it it is known uh uh
sometimes uh as other things, but
basically platform engineers have a
really tough job because they don't get
to build and ship cool software. They
get to enable all of you to build and
ship cool software in the most
productive way possible, right? Uh it's
a really tough job. It takes range. It
takes experience. It takes a lot of
patience. But we do it
for the endless gratification. You know,
just the gratitude we get from
developers. Just kidding.
No one ever says thank you. But it's
okay. Someone has to do it. Tough job.
Speaking of enabling,
anyone here use coding agents.
We are outnumbered. Okay. Well, I I want
to say to you, congratulations and
welcome to platform engineering.
Yeah, I mean your job now is to enable
robots to ship awesome software while
you spend more and more of your time
enabling them to do that productively,
right?
Tough job. I I I I
applaud you for giving up really the
most fun and rewarding part of the job.
You know,
very selfless. Uh yeah, so of course
this is not a completely a reality yet.
I mean we don't have quite yet the team
of agents just kind of you know humming
along doing the doing the job while we
sit back and um fix environments for
them. But you can kind of see it coming,
right? I mean some of you are definitely
doing that, hacking that together.
There's a lot of cool posts out there
and scripts and tools. Um so we know
it's coming. The question is how do we
enable this to um happen not just for
this incredibly
cool and uh bleeding edge crowd but for
everyone else uh like everyone shipping
software any everywhere just sort of
creating maximum value by enabling
agents to do the work for them
ultimately taking their jobs that is the
dream right
okay so yeah how do we do
and make it not too painful. Well, um I
want to go back to basics. What is an
agent? Uh the famous definition of
course is it's an LLM that's wrecking
everything in a loop on behalf of a
human.
Um,
oh man, that was supposed to be
animated. It's even better when it's
animated. It's okay. Yeah, you got one
agent and it's doing stuff in the
environment is your computer. Uh, and it
can do great work. It can all do also do
very crazy things. So, you have to kind
of watch it closely, right? And approve
approve. No, no, don't do that. That's
crazy. Yes, that's good. Um, that's kind
of the status quo today. But of course
um we want
to scale it, right? We want a team. So
how do we do that? Well, right now I
would say there are two options,
both equally wonderful and fun. The
first one I call yolo mode,
you know, I'll just run 10. What can
happen? Uh amazingly, this diagram is
not the worst case scenario,
but yeah, you know, you get the idea. So
that the whole methodology of watching
it closely just kind of falls apart
really quickly because they're all
stepping on each other's toes. They're
sharing an environment, right? Okay.
Enter option two. Oh, don't worry about
that. We'll run the agents, right? We'll
take care of everything. We've got
background mode. We've got them. We've
got the model. We've got the tools. We
got the environment. We've got the
compute. We got the secrets. We got
everything. You know, just open an
issue, wait for the PR, relax
until, of course, it doesn't work. And
then you're like, "No, that's not what I
meant."
Um these these actually work really
well. I think like 10 of those launched
just yet just just today and yesterday.
Um and and they're great. It's just that
um you know sometimes you just want to
get in there like okay give me the
keyboard you know and sometimes you just
want to run it on your machine or on
your favorite compute provider right use
your favorite model you want to mix and
match. So there are limitations to this
all-in-one model. So the question is is
there something better? uh is there just
a scenario where I just got a team and
they're working and you know I can step
in or leave them alone and we're just
kind of getting stuff done together. So
this is how I would summarize it. What I
would want is really four things. First,
I want background work. You know, I
don't want to be in there just watching
every action. That's obvious. Um I want
Rails. So that means I want to be able
to constrain the agent to to not just do
things that I already know are not
necessary. So obvious things like
context of the project, what's you know
what's our coding style, what's our what
tools to use, but also here's how to
build, here's how to test, here's the
base image we we use, right? You can
access this secret, you can access that.
Just an easy way to do that because
otherwise I'm going to waste so many
tokens just correcting as I go, right?
The third is inevitably when I do need
to step in I really I want a really
efficient and seamless way to do that
and it can't be watch every action and
it can't be just wait for the PR and do
code review you know there's I need a
middle ground here and the fourth thing
is I want optionality because like I was
saying before
it's a crazy market you know there's
there's awesome models awesome compute
awesome infrastructure uh agents are
really cool And as cool as they are now,
I mean, you one of you is probably like
launching one right now and then there's
another one tomorrow. So, I don't really
want to lock myself into a whole package
today and say no in advance to whatever
is coming out tomorrow. Not in this
market.
So,
to get that
um I need an environment that has
properties that match this. It needs to
be isolated, right? So, background work
works. It needs to be customizable so I
can set up those rails. needs to be
multiplayer so I can you know go all
right give me that let me fix this or
let me check did you do it you know when
the model says I did it did you do it
and then you know it should be open no
no shade on making money and scaling a
huge cloud service that's great you know
we have one they're great but I just
want choice right I want to be able to
choose and get the bo the best commodity
I'll just use this It's okay. It's okay
to use it. The best commodity component
for each uh job
and you know could even be open source.
Who knows? We could collaborate on this.
Anyway, so
unsurprisingly, maybe I'm going to talk
about containers now.
Someone actually said, you know, you
should check that they know Docker. They
know containers. Uh, okay. Who knows
what containers are? Who's used
containers?
Okay, cool. Cool. All right. boost my
confidence a little bit.
But the point here is we have the
technology it's not just about
containers, but they do play a crucial
role because it's a foundational
technology and it is it is
underutilized. We don't fully leverage
what this technology can do because
we're used to the first incarnation of
the tools made for humans. Uh same thing
for git. I see a lot of hacks involving
git work trees. Anyone playing with git
work trees to to get stuff done? Okay,
you know what I'm talking about. So this
is about that.
Um and of course we have models that are
incredibly smart and getting smarter and
they they can exercise these
technologies
uh really fully. We just need to
integrate them in a native way so that
we really
um tackle the problem at hand which is
giving great environments to these
agents. Anyway, so if we built that
native integration, what would it look
like? Well, we have a take sorry we a
dagger. I forgot completely to mention
my company. That's okay.
Um, it's great. Check it out. Um, we we
have a take on that. Something we call
container use. You know, there's
computer use, browser use. U, these
agents need container use. Um, they need
a way to use containers to create
environments and work inside of them.
This is not the same thing as
sandboxing, right? There are a lot of
ways to execute the output of the agent
in a secure sandbox. very useful, very
cool, but that's not the same thing as
the agent developing inside of
containers entirely, right? That's what
we're talking about here. So,
I asked my team,
hey, we've been developing this thing.
Oh, it's open source, but it's not yet
open source. Like, it's not finished.
But I asked the team, I should show it,
right? And they said, absolutely not.
It's not ready.
So anyway, you want to demo?
Okay.
All right. Just we're clear, this is you
agreeing to watch me stumble through a
broken demo of unfinished software. Yes.
Okay.
So much could go wrong right now.
This is my terminal. Can you see it?
Okay. For for technical reasons, I'm not
going to go to full screen. You just got
to stop me when I reach the edge. Oh,
actually I can see it. Never mind. Okay.
Yeah, old school.
Okay.
We used to do this all the time
in the old days. Okay. So,
uh here's what I'm going to do. I'm
going to just um try to develop
something very simple here. I got an
empty directory. And I'm going to try
try and make a little homepage for my
awesome container use project. And I'm
going to use cloud cloud code. Going to
try and use a bunch of them. Hopefully I
made something very clear. This is not a
coding agent. It's environments that are
portable that you can attach to any
coding agent. That's the idea. So you
like cloud, use cloud. You like, you
know, codecs, use codeex, etc., etc.,
etc. In an IDE, in the command line,
whatever. And also in the cloud, right?
in CI. Lots of cool things you can do
once you're async. So,
okay, one of the reasons the team said
don't do a demo is I'm actually terrible
at using cloud. So, uh I have an alias
for remembering the flag to disable all,
you know, permissions. I can never
remember it.
And I have a prompt here. It's I'll read
it to you in a minute, but it's
basically make me a homepage.
uh make it a go web app so I can know
what what's going on because I'm not a
cool kid writing TypeScript and run the
app when you're done. So while this runs
while this maybe runs hopefully. Okay.
Okay. Cool. So what's happening here is
I configured cloud code to use to you
know with container use to use
containers literally um via MCP. So it
was an MCP integration. There are other
integrations that we're working on but
MCP is the obvious place to start. Um,
and so now it has, you know, all its
usual tools. This is vanilla,
uh, cloud code, but now it can create an
environment for itself. And now it's
editing files in that environment like
in a little sandbox. And it can also run
commands to build it and test it and of
course run it in uh, ephemeral
containers. This is not one Docker
container sitting there. Every time an
action needs to be taken, there's an
ephemeral container running and then
being snapshotted and and uh, returning.
So it's just doing its thing. Um
what what I want to show you here. Okay.
So here I'm going to first show that
nothing has been polluting my workspace.
It's happening in a little sandbox. And
the way the sandbox works the state of
these files and the containers that are
being run is um actually persisted
uh in git and it's in a bunch of special
git objects that are kind of living
alongside the repo. So, it's right there
if I need it. This is all local. Um, but
it's not polluting my workspace by
default. So, hopefully it's going to
produce something soon. Uh, while it
does that, I'm going to use this little
command line. Is this readable? Okay,
little command line. CU like go work.
See you later. But no, really, it's for
container use. Um, and I can list
environments. And you can see there's a
new environment that's been created
here,
uh, with a little random name here. And
so there's a few things I can do. One
thing I can do is open a terminal.
And here, okay, this part is powered by
Dagger, right? But we use Dagger as a
sort of a toolbox. Just it has all the
primitives you need. Um,
and so here I can see exactly what the
agent sees, um, the files, but also the
tools. So I can see, okay, what what Go
version did you configure for yourself?
All right, because the model the the
agent is given the ability to figure out
what environment it needs and then
configure that but in a repeatable
containerized way. Uh so here I can see
okay does it build?
Okay, it builds. Okay, so you're done.
What's going on?
Okay, while we do that, I'm also going
to show you actually two more things to
say. One, uh a really cool feature of
this that I'm not going to show is
secrets. So you can just plug in secrets
from things like one password. I use one
password. I don't want to use a separate
password manager from an AI company. No
offense. I just want to use my password
manager. So I can just plug in and say
this environment gets this secret and
boom, it can use it, right? Um
and then the team said, "Please don't
show that. That's just that's going to
break for sure." Um so I won't. And the
other thing I want to say is that
because it's all powered by Dagger. Um
and the point here it's containers and
it's open source. That's what you should
know. Uh, it's running on my machine.
Actually, no, it's not running on my
machine because we're at a conference
and there's a lot of things that can go
wrong if you run containers and download
images. So, instead, I I just have it
running on my home server in my basement
about one mile this way. And it just
kind of works seamlessly. It's streaming
files up, streaming files down. It all
just kind of works. Um,
okay. This is the part that I cannot
control as you know. Um, okay. One more
thing I'll show you. You can watch. So
here I can see the history. So behind
the scenes every snapshot of the state
is like a git log. It's actually using
git under the hood. So if I'm happy with
the result, I can go and get it. Uh, so
it's like a happy medium between the
it's like a loop, a collaboration loop
that's just right. It's not watching
every tool and wrecking a shared
environment, but it's not waiting for a
pull request and, you know, having these
long back and forth. It's right in the
middle. I can see everything going on
and I can say, "Okay, give me the
history of that. I want that." Okay, it
says it's live. It's running. Oo, pretty
nice. Cool.
Okay, so now
Okay, I appreciate it, but you guys can
be honest. It's a little boring. So,
this design is boring.
Make it really pop.
Trying to impress
a engineering
there.
Okay.
Okay. So, the reason I'm doing that is
trying to create the circumstances where
I would need a lot of parallel
experiments, right? Make it pop. What
does that mean? It mean anything. What
if I want to try several experiments in
parallel, right? So, I'm just going to
say, oh,
well, hold on one second. Stop. Before I
do that, I'm going to um
merge this. Right? There's still nothing
here, but I'm saying I like it. So, I'm
going to say merge that environment.
And I have it. It's my history. I can
open a pull request, can clean it up,
whatever. So that's that's a loop that I
can work with, right? Um and now I can
say nah, boring.
And then I can say since the environment
is now in this state, I can ask for help
from a few other agents, right? I can
say okay, hey Claude Yolo,
uh that's not right.
Claude Yolo, this web app
looks a bit boring.
Can you make it pop please? Okay.
And
go
and go and go.
Okay. So, this is where things start
really going wrong. But
as the team pointed out, they said they
said, "Well, something's going to go
wrong, right?" They said, "Yeah, but you
were kind of showing that if things go
wrong, you can throw away the
environment and you're good. You can
restart." I say, "Okay, that's cool."
So, um, like let's say I don't like this
one. I'm like, "Nope. Goodbye. That's
it. I don't have to go clean up the
mess, right? That's the whole point."
Uh, okay. So, this is getting a little
messy. Oh, I wanted to show Goose also.
So, Goose is a really cool open source
agent. Whoops. All right. Hold on a
second. Goose YOLO. Same thing. Everyone
has complicated flags for disabling all
these safeties that I don't need
anymore, right? Because it's
Uh,
okay.
Okay. Well, really taking a chance here.
So, while this is happening,
uh, one thing we've been working on, but
I it's still work in progress is there's
a watch command. I showed you that
already, but as so as, um, this is a git
command, right? Thinly wrapped git
command. Our UX is really I cannot words
cannot express how unfinished this is
but
but it's it'll evolve rapidly because
the bones are strong. It's git, it's
dagger and you know it's your existing
agent, right? So it's and then a little
bit of glue. Uh so for example here is
literally it's a git command they can
copy paste. Uh, but as the agents work,
you're going to see states snapshotting
and you're going to see these branches
just kind of um diverging and then I can
diff them and apply them, merge them,
whatever I want. Um, and what I really
wanted to show and then I'm done is just
I just want to see one of them run. So
you can see when the agent runs a
service like and go in this case go run
npm run whatever it's doing it in its
containerized environment and that's
going to seamlessly be tunnneled to my
machine here on a different port without
any conflicts right so if when when I
say the environment's isolated it's it's
the files its context its configuration
and its execution right uh and the cool
the cool extra thing is all of this is
actually technically This here is
running in my basement. So you can go
crazy on the infrastructure side. Like
you can run this on a cluster. We like
to run this stuff from CI. Uh it's just
a lot of fun stuff you can do. And I'm
getting at 30 seconds.
Oh, Goose is Oh, Goose is running.
Great. Okay.
We did not solve prompt engineering. Do
it.
Okay. Not done. Not done. Oh man. Okay.
Well, just imagine.
[Laughter]
Okay. Well, uh, while this happens,
because I got 30 seconds left, I'm just
going to say,
um, thank you. And there's one last
thing I I want to say about Docker Con.
10 years ago, we used to open source
stuff on stage all the time. So, if you
want, I can go and open source it right
now.
Okay.
You have been warned though about the
not finished part, right? Okay.
Okay. Oh, I think my It would be funny
if the demo failed at the clicking on
GitHub part. Okay. All right. Goodbye.
Goodbye. Next time. I promise it works.
Okay. Haven't done this in a while.
Wait. Oh,
I'm almost done. The promise.
Come on. You did so well.
Change visibility.
Yes. I want Yes,
I have read and understand.
Oh, God.
Uh
yes.
At Dagger, we take security very
seriously.
Okay.
All right. I think it's Wait. I think
it's done.
Yes. Okay.
So, yeah, thank you very much. And it's
uh github.com/dagger/container
use. Come say hi, come participate. And
thank you so much for having me.
[Applause]
[Music]